Salut! Aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de faire une entrée en sautant
parce que c'est le jeudi et le jeudi je fais ce que je veux
Comme cette semaine on a déjà fait une vidéo un peu participative
avec tout le jeu pour Skype, avec Julie, etc.
Je reviens aux fondamentaux du jeudi
on revient sur une de mes passions
qui est pas si éloignée que ça du mentalisme
ce sont les énigmes
et aujourd'hui, je vous soumets trois énigmes
La première énigme, c'est une énigme d'allumettes
avec 10 allumettes, vous construisez un cerf vu de profil
ou un cerf qui a un satellite. ça on va dire que c'est un cerf vu de profil
et en face vous mettez une onzième allumette
Cette allumette là, elle représente la balle d'un chasseur.
Y'a un chasseur qui tire sur l'élan et la balle arrive près de l'élan
et va le... le tuer, malheureusement.
Et est-ce que la team Mentalo veut qu'on tue des élans?
Non! On ne veut pas ça. Donc vous devez sauver cet élan.
Et pour ça, il va vous falloir un élan d’ingéniosité.
*musique : Dr. Dre - The Next Episode*
Vous avez le droit de bouger une allumette et seulement une allumette
pour que l'élan évite la balle
Vous devez pouvoir résoudre cette énigme en bougeant une allumette
La situation sera assez évidente pour qu'on comprenne que l'élan ne sera pas touché par cette balle.
Un indice quand même : la méthode de résolution de cette énigme là
c'est qu'il faut changer votre point de vue.
Il faut changer votre perception.
Et je vous donnerais la réponse qu'à la fin de cette vidéo, bien sûr!
Deuxième énigme : c'est celle des trois lumières.
Y en a peut être qui la connaisse
Je la trouve très pertinente.
Pour moi c'est un peu une logique à la Sherlock Holmes.
Comme quand on a parlé de Sherlock Holmes dans ce Master Class là.
Vous allez vous mettre devant une porte.
Derrière cette porte il y a une pièce vide, noire, avec une ampoule qui descend du plafond.
A côté de la porte, du côté où vous êtes vous.
Il y a trois interrupteurs.
Sachant que vous n'avez le droit d'ouvrir la porte qu'une seule fois,
de quelle manière pouvez-vous déterminer à 100%,
en étant sûr à 100%, lequel des trois interrupteurs allume la lumière?
Donc tout le but de l'énigme est là, vous n'avez le droit d'ouvrir la porte qu'une seule fois
Y'a pas d'embrouilles du genre on peut voir la lumière par la serrure ou pas
ou sous la porte ou pas.
Ne cherchez pas par là, pour résoudre l'énigme il faut être capable de dire comment vous procéderiez
pour pouvoir affirmer à 100% quel interrupteur commande l'ampoule qui est de l'autre côté de la porte.
Et vous n'avez le droit d'ouvrir la porte qu'une seule fois.
Et je l'ai pas précisé tellement cela me paraissait évident :
Une fois que la porte est ouverte, vous n'avez plus le droit de toucher aux interrupteurs, bien sûr!
Je vous laisse réfléchir à ça!
Petit indice comme tout à l'heure, c'est une énigme vraiment purement de logique.
Eh! C'est la team Mentalo ou c'est pas la team Mentalo?
Dernière énigme où la méthode de résolution est plus mathématique là
C'est une énigme un peu plus connue je pense, moi je l'avais connue à l'époque dans...
ce livre : les énigmes de Dante.
Je vous en mettrez quelques uns dans le descriptif, tiens.
C'est l'énigme du bédouin et de ses chameaux.
Y'a un bédouin dans le désert qui décède
Il a 17 chameaux
Tout le monde est triste évidemment mais c'est pas la question
Il avait surtout décidé de les léguer à ses trois enfants
Le testament disait : le premier de mes enfants, l’aîné
prendra les deux tiers de mes chameaux
le second prendra la moitié de mes chameaux
et le dernier prendra un neuvième de mes chameaux
et il avait 17 chameaux
et là les frangins se disent : on va quand même pas couper en deux les chameaux de papa
Nos trois frangins vont chez le sage, le sage du desert, "el sage del deserto"
et il leur trouve une solution, il leur trouve la solution
et à vous maintenant de montrer que vous êtes aussi malin que le sage
C'est pas une solution où on mutile un chameau
y'a encore une fois pas d'embrouilles spéciales
c'est purement mathématique, c'est un raisonnement mathématique
que je vous laisse chercher!
Si vous voulez faire pause maintenant ou revenir sur la vidéo plus tard
pour vérifier vos réponses, faites-le.
Si vous aimez les énigmes, je vais vous mettre quelques uns de mes bouquins d'énigmes préférés
dans le descriptif.
Y en a qui sont sous forme d'enquête policière qui sont vraiment bien genre...
celui-ci là, "menez l'enquête"
Y'a plein d'indices, de témoignages, de mises en situation
et on doit retrouver le coupable
Et maintenant je vous donne les réponses!
Pour éviter la balle, je vais prendre l'allumette qui est ici,
je vais la placer ici.
Et là pour l'instant vous ne voyez peut être pas pourquoi il va éviter la balle
Eh bien tout simplement parce qu'on a changé de point de vue
Y'a quelques secondes il était de profil
et là il faut imaginer une vue de dessus
Il vient de s'écraser comme ça, il vient de s'aplatir comme ça contre le sol.
et en conséquence, la balle n'est plus sur le même plan
elle va lui passer par au-dessus.
C'est une belle galère mais elle est vraiment intéressante
sur le fait qu'il faut changer son axe de réfléxion en fait,
pour pouvoir trouver certaines solutions.
Pour la réponse de la deuxième énigme
Vous allez allumer le premier interrupteur, le deuxième interrupteur
et vous attendez trois minutes
comme ça, tranquille
Au bout de trois minutes vous éteignez le premier interrupteur
vous ouvrez la porte
et là il y a trois possibilités
Ou la lumière est allumée et donc là vous savez que c'est l'interrupteur numéro 2
puisque lui il est resté allumé
si la lumière est éteinte, vous rentrez dans la pièce et vous allez toucher l'ampoule.
Si l'ampoule est chaude, ça veut dire que c'est l'interrupteur numéro 1 qui commande l'ampoule.
Comme il a été allumée trois minutes, l'ampoule a chauffé, donc vous le savez comme ça.
Et si l'ampoule est froide, c'est l'interrupteur numéro 3 que vous n'avez jamais touché.
Et la réponse à la troisième énigme, celle des chameaux,
il y a donc 17 chameaux, le premier des frères doit prendre un tiers des chameaux,
le deuxième, la moitié des chameaux et le dernier, un neuvième des chameaux.
Je sais. Au début de l'énigme, je corrigerai en post-prod, j'ai dit deux tiers
il me semble, au lieu d'un tiers.
Je vérifierai ça quand je monterai la vidéo
et je rajouterai un truc par au-dessus
mais c'est bien un tiers, un demi et un neuvième.
Bref, impossible d'appliquer ce testament là sur 17 chameaux,
Puisque le résultat ne tombe pas juste,
il nous faut des chameaux entiers.
Le sage dit : j'ai la solution, vous prenez mon chameau,
je vous le donne pour appliquer le testament.
Si vous aimez les chiffres mais même de très très loin, n'ayez pas peur,
vous allez adorer la réponse.
Le sage offre son chameau, donc ça fait 17 chameaux + un chameau, ça fait 18 chameaux.
Le premier des frères prend donc un tiers des 18 chameaux, donc 6 chameaux.
Le deuxième frère prend la moitié des 18 chameaux donc 9 chameaux.
et le dernier frère prend un neuvième des 18 chameaux donc 2 chameaux.
Le sage dit : partez chacun avec vos chameaux, j'veux plus vous voir.
Donc il y en a un qui part avec 9 chameaux, l'autre avec 6 chameaux, l'autre avec 2 chameaux.
9 + 6 + 2, ça donne 17.
Y'a un chameau qui reste sur place, c'est celui du sage,
le 18ème, le sage le prend et rentre tranquillement.
Merci d'avoir regardé ce petit hors-sujet du jeudi
j'espère que ça vous aura plu.
Si c'est le cas, y'a une énigme, vous pouvez laisser quelque chose qui commence par "pouce"
et qui finit par "en l'air".
pour me le faire savoir.
Vous pouvez également commenter la vidéo, n'oubliez pas que je lis tous les commentaires!
Même si j'ai quelques jours de retard dans mes réponses,
je suis quand même au taquet.
Et si vous n'êtes pas abonnés, faites-le avant de partir
parce que le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
donc rendez-vous demain à 17h, ciao!